a plane crash is a violent event whether
it's a midair fire and impact with
another aircraft or smashing into the
ground the remains are typically bent
burnt and mangled and it's sobering to
remember that all the aircraft you have
here are actual aircraft that have been
involved in crashes usually with a
fatality somehow air crash investigators
have to figure out what happened
this warehouse part of the University of
Southern California houses what's left
of 11 aircraft and instructors use them
to train future crash detectives this is
a mitsubishi mu-2 a small turboprop
plane typically used by companies for
their exacts we look down the length of
the fuselage and we see a lot of the
energy being absorbed here without the
internet without the energy being
conducted through the rest of the
fuselage tells us that a the vector of
the energy was like this but also that
it wasn't going that fast this crash was
caused by ice accumulating on the wings
causing a stall at low altitude the
plane impacted the ground on the front
corner a stall is not a critical thing
unless it's very close to the ground you
can recover from a stall if you're at
out if you have enough altitude this is
indicative of just how much force is
involved in an aircraft crash look at
all these pieces just from one small
plane and you can imagine that at one
point these I'm guessing we're probably
in a field or judging by the amount of
mud and dirt on these pieces so somebody
had to collect these and then piece them
back together like this enormous jigsaw
puzzle as they tried to figure out
exactly what happened here it's not just
fixed-wing aircraft this is an is 350 B
from Airbus helicopters the type popular
with law enforcement when we're looking
at a helicopter the dynamics are quite
different let's go back here because one
of the things about a helicopter that is
is most critical is this tail rotor this
tail rotor was swinging to the right and
then if we look again at this tail rotor
we see it is deformed as well give us
the shortcut what actually happened to
this helicopter well in this case it
became involved in what's called vortex
ring state in which the downwash from
the aircraft forces down on the main
rotor system that's the one that lifts
it up and as the power is applied it
actually forces the aircraft down even
more so it made a really hard heavy
landing did it tip a little bit as well
when I look at it I so it's obviously
tipped a little bit to the right it
actually struck a pickup truck it's hard
to believe but even a burnt-out wreck
like this can reveal a lot of detail
about the moments before a crash what
we're looking for is like a flame type
of deformation and in fact we find it
here this has burnt away the burn away
the paint so that will give us some
indication of how hot and how long the
fire was or the heat was was in
existence this being the hottest part
and the least paint being burnt away
this really gives us a good clue that
there was a source of heat or fire that
occurred while the aircraft was in the
air she's doing this sort of trial here
this teardrop shape is where flames or
heat would have been pushed backwards
because the aircraft was still moving
forwards through the air yes as it was
burning over 700 trainees come through
this warehouse every year honing their
skills air travel is statistically very
safe but if the worst does happen
they'll be prepared and what they learn
from wrecks like this could stop the
next one happening
you